today on the matt walsh show the jury in
the rittenhouse case gets it right while
the media explodes in a blind rage we'll
talk about the fallout from the not
guilty verdict today and a man plows
through a christmas parade in wisconsin
injuring dozens and killing many many
aspects of this case make it
inconvenient for the corporate media
we'll talk about those facts today and
fauci officially recommends boosters for
all people over 18 plus the fight for 15
movement has now become the fight for 25
movement who could have seen that coming
we'll talk about all that much more
today the matt wall show
[Music]
as an increasing number of companies
fall all over themselves trying to
appeal to the left wouldn't it be nice
to find one that supports your values
well i have one you already know what
i'm going to tell you charity mobile
charity mobile is the pro-life phone
company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life pro
family charity of your choice with five
percent of your monthly plan price and
they've sent millions of dollars to
charities so far
and they also offer a great service new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh plus you get a free christmas
gift with every phone from charity
mobile while supplies last
that's another thing you're not going to
get from other companies is a christmas
gift they especially won't call it a
christmas gift like charity mobile does
charity mobile makes it easy to switch
you can keep your existing phone number
and you may even be able to keep your
existing phone as well if you need a new
phone no problem they got you covered
there too and they also have new flip
phones with parental controls that allow
you to disable
mobile uh data usage text and picture
messaging and more which is so important
if you're a parent and you're gonna get
your kid a cell phone make sure you get
one of those kinds of phones so they
can't go on the internet
you get all of that from charity mobile
while again helping to build a culture
of life in america so switch to charity
mobile and support the causes you care
about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at cherrymobile.com and mention offer
code walsh it's tempting to say that
justice was done on friday when the
verdict in the kyle rittenhouse trial
was returned and kyle was found not
guilty on all counts
it was certainly a just verdict the
right verdict but we can't say that
justice was done unless and until all of
the people responsible for this
political show trial are held
accountable the prosecutor should be
disbarred the media who smeared kyle as
a white supremacist serial killer should
be sued into bankruptcy their lives
should be ruined
they should suffer
we should want them to suffer for it
because that's justice
and that still would not even the score
it wouldn't set everything right because
they have taken something from kyle
rittenhouse that he can never get back
namely his entire normal life the life
he ought to have lived is gone
he is free as he should be but he'll
never really be free from the slander
and defamation that's what makes slander
and defamation so insidious
he'll have to walk around with the
scarlet r racist on his head forever
because that's the reality that the
media has constructed for him
and this is why they should pay and pay
dearly
it's not a no harm no foul situation
they have done immense harm to kyle
rittenhouse and done it on purpose with
malice in their hearts
and they aren't done after the verdict
was right on friday the the demons in
the corporate media convulsed and
screamed and vomited like a scene
straight out of the exorcist
watching msnbc on friday as i did for a
couple of hours purely for the
entertainment i have expected to see
someone's head do a like 360 degree turn
they were apoplectic in their demonic
rage
and they were not prepared to surrender
their narrative or back away from it
even an inch
many examples of course we could play
for you you've probably seen a lot of
them but we'll settle on just a couple
first here's uh one of the hobgoblins on
msnbc tiffany cross
having a rather ghoulish temper tantrum
watch
i find these people disgusting ellie i'm
disgusted at what i'm seeing it's not
just this trial it's other trials but
this in particular the fact that white
supremacists roam the halls of congress
freely and celebrate this little
murderous white supremacist and the fact
that he gets to walk the streets freely
it lets you know these people have
access to instituting uh laws they
represent the legislative branch of this
country what are we to make of that
welcome to the modern republican party
this is what these people want and this
is what a majority of white people vote
for right when i say that a majority of
white people are in favor of this kind
of violence it is because a majority of
white people consistently vote
republican consid you know since the
passage of the civil rights act a
majority of white people have voted
republican right so like this is the
party that they're supporting a majority
of white people pick judges like bruce
schrader the judge in the kyle
rittenhouse case a majority of white
people do not support policies that
would unpack and unroll and reform this
system of justice this is what they want
matt gates is giving the white folks
what they want look at it
look at yourselves
it's gross
but until a majority of you
stop voting for this
this will keep happening
i may have misheard it but did he snort
like a pig there
i don't know it's i mean if it oinks
like a pig you know what they say
little murderous white supremacist
is what uh kyle ryden house is called
there after the verdict he was found not
guilty of murder and he's not a white
supremacist there was never any reason
to think that he was a white supremacist
there's never been even one single
slight shred of evidence that he's a
white supremacist he shot three white
people in self-defense as the court of
law just declared by the way a majority
of white people are in favor of this
kind of violence i don't know where he's
getting this from but i'll tell you as
one white person yeah you're damn right
i am in favor
of violence in self-defense where you're
killing a child rapist who's trying to
kill you i'm in favor of that violence
all day every day
but msnbc will stick with the fantasy
scenario it constructed early on the
people at msnbc and across the corporate
media and the american left
they arrived at a conclusion about the
written house case within three minutes
of the last shot being fired
and they have not wavered from it even
the smallest bit since that initial
moment
that's because the truth doesn't matter
at all we'll get back to that point in a
moment but first here's another example
somehow uh even more delusional
this is someone named amber ruffin who
has some kind of show on msnbc or
peacock or whatever uh here she is
you guys because i have my own show i
have a responsibility to say things that
people need to know
that aren't being said
it's a cool opportunity that i don't
take lightly there are very big
obvious truths that no one wants to say
on tv but i will now just a few minutes
before we started taping the show kyle
rittenhouse the man accused of shooting
three people during a black lives matter
protest was declared not guilty on all
charges so
i can't believe i have to say this but
it's not okay
for a man
to grab a rifle
travel across state lines
and shoot three people and then walk
free
it's not okay for the judicial system
to be blatantly and obviously stacked
against people of color
it's not okay
for there to be an entirely different
set of rules
for white people
state lines
i mean i get really emotional about
state lines also you travel across state
lines in fact i'm worried now
after the written house verdict that
this will set a precedent
and now people will feel
entitled to just cross state lines
whenever they want i i'm i'm worried
that you know slippery slope situation
that that next thing you know we're
going to have a whole a system of roads
set up like like um maybe we need like
an interstate highway system they might
build where people just cross state
lines whenever they want uh that's what
i'm worried about
by the way um you know how kyle ray
house was accused of crocodile tears
because he was uh he was uh he you know
had he had an emotional breakdown while
on trial to trying to save his life
um those were not crocodile tears if you
want to know what crocodile tears look
like which is what you just saw there
amber ruffin that's what that's what
fake crying looks like
and literally every single thing she
said
is wrong every word
starting with the pretense that what she
said there was somehow bold and brave
and something that nobody else is
willing to say she simply repeated the
same thing that everyone in corporate
media is saying and has said a million
times already yet pretends that this
requires courage
that nobody's gonna say this
except the last seven million people you
heard say it so i'll say it
no courage and shamelessness are not the
same amber though i realize this
distinction is often lost on the left
she also says that he grabbed a rifle
and crossed state lines and murdered
people none of that is true
we know that it's not true the facts are
incontrovertibly against her but what
does she care
as for the justice system being stacked
against people of color
that seems an odd claim given that
nobody involved in this case was a
person of color black people have
nothing to do with this case
i understand that black supremacists
might struggle to understand that point
but it has nothing to do this this was a
case involving white people
is it true that only white murder
defendants get off on self-defense
claims
well no in fact on the very same day on
friday at almost the exact same time
that kyle rittenhouse was acquitted of
his murder charges on the basis of
self-defense a man down in florida
andrew coffey
was also found not guilty of murder and
attempted murder on the grounds of
self-defense after shooting at a swat
team that came into his house
unannounced
that acquittal was again on the same day
andrew coffey is black
on the same
day
he's not alone amy swearer a legal
fellow at heritage has a great thread on
twitter documenting many recent cases of
black defendants being acquitted of
murder charges on the grounds of
self-defense it happens all the time it
is very very common
the media might not tell you about it
but it happens
there is simply no evidence at all no
reason to believe at all
that kyle rittenhouse would have been
convicted if he was black
there is no evidence at all no reason to
believe at all that self-defense laws
disproportionately help white people
there is no data to back that up none
in fact the opposite is probably the
case the daily caller ran an analysis um
back in 2013 in florida
to see who benefits the most from the
state's standard ground law
and they discovered that black people
are disproportionate beneficiaries of
that law
okay black person in florida is more
likely to be acquitted on self-defense
than a white person
and there's plenty of reason to believe
that this trend holds true across the
nation
that won't stop the narrative or even
slow it down
just as the left has not held itself
back from anointing joseph rosenbaum and
anthony huber martyrs for the case
even as a court of law just effectively
found them both to be attempted
murderers i mean that's the
the implication here if it was
self-defense on rittenhouse's side
then it was attempted murder on their
side
and that's the most flattering thing on
their resumes rosenbaum as you know from
the show was a serial child rapist a
pedophile sodomite who anally raped
young boys
yet protesters took to the street after
the verdict and chanted rosenbaum's name
listen to this
say his name joseph
rosenbaum that's almost as sickening as
the tributes that have poured in from
hollywood actor pedro
pascal tweeted joseph rosenbaum 36 and
anthony huber 27 murdered august 25th
2020
rest in peace
now the best i can say about that
statement
is that it's a bit optimistic
rosenbaum a serial child rapist who died
while trying to kill a teenage boy is
almost certainly burning in hell
you know that say his name joseph
rosenbaum we can imagine the legions in
hell that's what greeted
uh rosenbaum as he was walking
down the hallway
god's forgiveness of course knows no
bounds but considering his last moment
on earth was spent trying to murder a
teenager it seems unlikely that he had
any sort of last-minute repentance or
conversion meanwhile mark ruffalo
tweeted
quote we come together to mourn the
lives lost to the same racist system
that devalues black lives and devalued
the lives of anthony and jojo
hashtag reimagine kenosha
yes
that's a major hollywood actor using a
cutesy pet name for a serial child
rapist
talk about saying the quiet part out
loud i mean these hollywood perverts are
so used to hanging out with child
molesters and rapists that they feel
bonds of affection even with the rapists
they've never met
so perhaps i assume too much for all i
know rosenbaum and ruffalo went to the
same parties who knows
either way add rosenbaum to the list of
recent heroes and martyrs of the left
it's a list that includes george floyd
a man who forced his way into a woman's
home and robbed her at gunpoint
jacob blake a violent felon an alleged
rapist and woman abuser who assaulted
police brandished a knife
got shot while trying to steal a car and
kidnap children
rayshard brooks a felon who passed out
drunk at a fast food drive-thru lane
then got himself shot while fighting
with the cops and stealing their taser
dante wright a wanted criminal who
sexually assaulted a woman and robbed
her at gunpoint
now now to this pantheon this mount
rushmore of deviants and demons we can
add joseph rosenbaum child molester and
rapist
these are the men that the left bids us
to celebrate and admire
the absolute worst source of people
human society has to offer
the dregs of humanity
the bottom of the barrel these are meant
to be our our martyrs
so what's going on here between the
celebration of joseph rosenbaum all of
the lies told about kyle rittenhouse
what we have to understand is that the
left is not just building a narrative
though they are doing that
but more so they're creating an entire
new reality
their ultimate goal is to construct an
alternate
universe
you know i give a talk on college
campuses called the war on reality about
the left's efforts to redefine life
marriage and gender and the title is not
hyperbole
i mean they have waged war on reality
itself truth itself
and as i argue in the talk the three
main pillars of this effort the three
primary modes of attack are to redefine
these fundamental elements of human
civilization
their battle plan has been such a
success thus far that many people in our
society today will look you in the eyes
and flatly deny that any such thing as
truth or objective reality exists
the upshot is that with something like
the written house verdict
it's fruitless to argue that the left's
narrative isn't true or that it
contradicts the facts they know that and
they don't care or i should say
contradicting the facts is the whole
point
telling a leftist that their claims
about some event are untrue it's like
reading a sci-fi novel and objecting
that none of that happened in real life
it's a fantasy
well yeah that's the point
the only difference between the sci-fi
novel and the claims made by the leftist
is that the fictional reality in the
book is supposed to be contained only in
the book for the leftist we're all meant
to live in his fictional reality we're
supposed to pretend that it's real
a world governed by self-identity and
emotional whim a reality that is
malleable
which changes to accommodate political
and ideological needs
that's the objective
that's what's at stake
and it's time we understand that
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
as we get into the holidays you got to
think about buying gifts we have
thanksgiving coming up and we know how
expensive food is i mean i can't imagine
putting together a thanksgiving dinner
what that's going to cost us
all that means is that you got to save
money wherever you can and that's why
you need to get the get upside app my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now use promo code walsh and get a bonus
25 cents per gallon on your first fill
up that's up to 50 cents cash back you
don't have to pay full price of the pump
um you can get cash back using get
upside just download the app for free
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cashback on your first
tank 25 cents a gallon thereafter some
people who drive a lot are making two
300 a month i've talked to people making
that kind of money um and there's no
cash the cash back is added right to
your account and it really is as easy as
that you can cash out any time to your
bank account paypal you can even get
gift cards and you know that could be
part of your christmas gift to somebody
just download the free get upside app
and use promo code walls to get up to 50
cents a gallon cash back on your first
tank that's code walsh
all right so i want to jump right into
this
um
horrible horrible case in
waukesha i think i'm pronouncing that
right will kesha in wisconsin
and it just so happens that um this was
a you know this this happened at a
christmas parade in wisconsin
i think maybe less than an hour away
from kenosha
this was on sunday and they were having
their christmas parade and a car
an suv
drove through the middle of the parade
and uh
as of the last time i checked before we
started filming
the the death toll now is five with more
than 40 people injured many of them kids
because these were kids who were in the
parade you know dancing and singing all
that kind of stuff
and this car just goes right through the
parade and keeps on driving
um
now let me read this from the
post-millennial and there's a lot of
information we still don't have i mean
this happened last night and there's
information coming in and so
um
of of what i report right now i'm not
sure what of this will will still be
relevant by the time you listen to this
but
this is from the post-millennial it says
a suspect has been identified as in
custody for the mass casualty incident
in waukesha wisconsin when a red ford
escape uh plowed into a holiday parade
so far five had been confirmed dead more
than 40 injured
according to court documents 39 year old
daryl edward brooks has been arrested as
a suspect in the incident
brooks is a career criminal with
multiple priors and was released from
jail two days prior to the incident
after posting a one thousand dollar bail
for three misdemeanors and two
felonies thousand dollar bail
so you've got a career criminal
multiple convictions
charged with uh with um five
criminal counts two of them felonies
and he had a thousand dollar bill
he has a history of resisting arrest
obstruction battery statutory sexual
seduction strangulation suffocation
property destruction illegal firearm
possession bail jumping
domestic violence drug-related charges
and is a registered sex offender
and they let him out on a thousand
dollars bail
again one of his prior crimes is bail
jumping
the driver of the red suv plowed through
a police line at high speed and into a
parade of christmas marchers on sunday
impacting more than 20 adults and
children in a graphic scene captured on
the city's live stream and cell phones
of bystanders
uh you can
i mean i've seen some of the video of
this i don't recommend uh
watching it i mean as you can imagine
extremely disturbing
but there is there's so there are some
important details that you find when you
watch these videos and we'll get to that
in a second
now a little bit more on daryl brooks
which the post-millennial reports he's
the person of interest
in a rap video on his youtube page
brooks is seen dancing in front of a red
ford escape the same type of vehicle
used in sunday's fatal incident
wakeshow wisconsin police chief daniel
thompson confirmed in a press release
following the tragedy that an officer
who's been on the force for over six
years opened fire on the vehicle and
that a person of interest was in custody
uh thompson emphasized that the
investigation is quote very active
okay then we go over to
uh what
the corporate media is saying
and what we're being told so far and
again this could change
but initial reports
and uh the media has been
very very short to report this and in
fact cnn on cnn.com on their on their
website
there's a big headline announcing this
that
as it stands right now what they're
telling us is that there was no
particular motive in this crime
that he in fact was fleeing from another
crime and that's why he drove right
through a parade so here is the
local
uh nbc affiliate
it says brooks has not formally been
identified as a suspect by police and
has not been charged with a crime
the motive behind the incident remains
unclear earlier on monday a law
enforcement official said investigators
are examining whether the person of
interest in this case may have been
fleeing from a crime when he sped into
the parade goers
the investigators were questioning a
person in custody about that incident
which the official described as an
altercation involving a knife
the official who cautioned that the
investigation was still
in the early stages and was continued
continuing to develop could not discuss
the investigation so that's um
that's what we're being told yeah the
headline on cnn says suspect in parade
tragedy may have been fleeing another
scene
okay
so a few things here
and we should also mention that daryl
brooks is a black man okay and that's
relevant
because it might speak to why we can't
necessarily trust what the media tells
us
all right
we know las vegas that was a white guy
in las vegas but 50 over 50 people were
shot and killed years ago
and to this day we've never been told
why he did it
almost every other mass shooting mass
killing in recent memory um we've got a
pretty good idea of the motive they tell
us like almost right away
years later with with uh las vegas they
never told us the motive
i'm wondering
if it'll be a similar thing with
waukesha
no i i wouldn't be surprised if two
years from now people are saying hey
remember that thing that happened when
the guy plowed through
a parade and killed a bunch of children
why did he do that whatever happened
with that
i would not be surprised if the same
thing happens here
uh because already
you know the early narrative what
they're trying to convince us is that
this was i guess basically unintentional
and that he was trying to flee the scene
of another crime
now in terms of of sentencing
it really shouldn't make a difference
because if this was intentional he was
trying to kill a bunch of people or if
this was callous disregard for human
life and he didn't care if he killed a
bunch of people either way uh it should
be really it should be a death sentence
it should be an eye for an eye sentence
where you strap him down on the road and
then a parade of cars runs over him
until he dies that's what i believe in
now as it happens it was constant they
don't have the death penalty anymore as
far as i know
but it should still be
life in a cage never leaving ever again
regardless of the motive given how many
people died
but even so
um
was this intentional he was just trying
to flee
the scene of another crime i don't
believe that for a second
and i get very suspicious
when i hear a motive like that
proposed as a possibility
and that there's really no motive
because you can you can see the video
it is very clear in the videos that he
is intentionally targeting people
i mean the car turns so that he hits
more people
now if you're fleeing the scene of a
crime you're just trying to get away and
let's say you don't really care that
much if you hit people but you your main
motivation is you want to you want to
get away from from from the cops
well for one thing you'd probably go
around the parade
just for the sake of going faster you go
around but also you would start honking
your horn you would try to steer around
people again if even if you don't care
about their lives it's going to let you
go faster if you don't hit anybody so it
just doesn't make it easy he never honks
his horn never announces that he's
coming
makes no attempt to go around anybody
he goes through multiple intersections
and never turns
and yet we're being told that
potentially he was just fleeing the
scene of another crime i don't believe
it
i don't buy it
now what we know is that this person of
interest is a black man and um
there are indications there are reports
that he was at a minimum a blm supporter
and he appears to have rap videos where
he's got a lot of anti-white rhetoric
and that sort of thing
so you have to wonder
did that have anything to do with this
was he at all motivated i mean is it a
coincidence that this happened only a
few miles away from kenosha
a couple of days after the verdict
is it just a coincidence that the
verdict happens and then may and then
apparently a blm supporter plows through
a um a parade of mostly white people is
is i mean it could be
it could be
but um
i don't believe the initial narrative
i'll just tell you that i personally
don't believe it it doesn't make any
sense it does not pass the common sense
smell test
and the problem is
now let's just say that there is some
element of
and it could be a combination of these
things i mean it could be he's fleeing
the scene of a crime he figures his life
is over anyway sees a crime of
opportunity here might as well take out
some people you know
so there could be a combination of that
kind of motive who i don't know
but um
the problem is that let's just say
theoretically hypothetically
that there is at least some element of
motive here
and that he was targeting these people
as he really appears to be doing in the
video
and that he was um
he was
spurred on in that direction by a lot of
the misreporting and the false
narratives in the media
well if that were the case then we'd be
relying on the media to tell us
that it's their fault partly that this
happened
i don't trust the media to tell me that
so we're in a position with this uh with
this case that
hey we we're probably going to be las
vegas we're never going to know the
truth
because whatever the media tells me
about this i i can't believe it i don't
trust it i do not trust what you're
telling me corporate media
if if if the reality of this case
is extremely inconvenient for you and
your narrative i don't believe that you
will tell me
and then when they're insulting our
intelligence early on by saying that
potentially he was just fleeing the
scene of a crime give me a break
and of course we know that you know
reverse the race is here
if this was a white man plowing through
a parade of mostly black people um
the corporate media
immediately within like a second along
with every elected democrat they would
be saying this is racially motivated
this is a hate crime that's what they'd
be saying
i'm not even saying that because i i
don't know
what i'm saying is that to me seems like
at least a possibility
and the story they're telling us early
on doesn't make sense to me and i don't
believe it
um there's another aspect of this case
that we do that that appears to be
pretty well established
that this man if he in fact was the
guilty party um
career criminal out on bail
and so this is what this is what bail
reform
and justice reform gets us
whether or not false media narratives
are partly to blame i suspect they might
be
but we certainly know that bail reform
justice reform
shares some of the blame here
because this man never should have been
out of prison in the first place
okay there has to be a point
where we as as a society can say
um and this is what three strikes
strike laws we're supposed to be about
there has to be a point where we as a
society can say to someone okay
you've made it clear to us that you have
no interest in living in society as a
civilized human being you've made it
clear to us
that you want to be
that you want to act like an animal
and so
that's how you're going to be treated
we're going to put you in a cage for the
rest of your miserable life there has to
be a point where we can say that as as a
society the idea that we we keep cycling
these people through the system and
putting them back on the street until
they do something so heinous
that that even the most progressive d.a
would have to go for a life and sentence
uh a life in in prison sentence you know
that
system that strategy
doesn't work
it results directly in these sorts of
things
because whether they say it or not that
is you know that's that's the strategy
that these progressive das many of them
um put in their position
partly through funding from george soros
and other um
other uh you know wealthy activists
but whether they say it explicitly or
not
that's their strategy that's their
philosophy
that they're going to keep putting
people back on the street keep putting
them back on the street back on the
street until they do something until
they at least kill someone and even then
we they still might end up back on the
street
all right um
let's move on here kyle rittenhouse was
interviewed in fact he's uh he has an
interview with tucker carlson
in fact it came out that uh tucker
carlson has been filming a documentary
about kyle rittenhouse throughout the
trial so that'll be very interesting to
watch but he's got an interview with
kyle rittenhouse that'll be released
tonight i believe on tucker's show and
there was a preview of that interview
that came out on sunday and he made uh
rittenhouse made a surprising comment
that based on what i saw the reaction on
social media even some people on the
right are criticizing him for this i
think that's unfair but let's listen to
kyle here
this has nothing to do with race
it never had anything to do with race it
had to do with the right to self-defense
right
i'm not a racist person i support the
blm movement i support peacefully
demonstrating
and i believe there needs to be change i
believe there's a lot of prosecutorial
misconduct not just in my case but in
other cases
okay so he says i support the blm
movement now um
like i said i saw some criticism
even on the right towards kyle
rittenhouse for that comment
um
i don't blame the kid for this i don't
think it's fair at all to criticize him
he's worried for his own safety and his
family's safety number one
and also remember something that
democrats are pushing for a federal
investigation they have not let this go
and they're not going to let it go
they're going to pursue this this this
man this young man for the rest of his
life
um but now they're pushing for a federal
investigation so i'm sure from kyle
rittenhouse's perspective and i'm sure
he's also been told this by his lawyer i
don't know that but i would assume that
his lawyers maybe have said something
like this
um that if he makes any comments
publicly that could it all be construed
as in any way critical of blm
then that
will open the door
for them to you know come after him
officially
it shouldn't be that way of course but
that's how it is
so i you know i i wouldn't criticize him
at all after everything he's been
through to say that um still it does
show what what sort of stranglehold
leftist grievous grievance organizations
like blm have
that even kyle rittenhouse after blm i
mean they they are the ones
who tried to lynch him they are the
lynch mob
here and even after going through all of
that
he will still say feels like he has to
say that he supports the very lynch mob
that came after him
i say that not as a criticism of kyle
rittenhouse but more of the lynch mob
itself that that this is what this is
the society they've created
uh but i'll be interested to see the
rest of that interview on tucker
carlson's show tonight next uh anthony
fauci now officially recommends boosters
for everyone over the age of 18 and that
will soon of course be everyone of all
ages but here he is on cnn
do you recommend that every single
american 18 and older get a booster shot
absolutely dana let's make it clear you
know when there's lack of clarity people
get confused they're not sure what to do
if you are 18 or older and you've been
vaccinated fully vaccinated with the
modern or the fisa mrna
six months or more ago
get a booster if it's j and j
and it's two months ago or more get a
boost i don't think we should get hung
up on should may just go out and get
boosted we know they're safe and we know
they're highly effective and bringing
very very high up the optimization of
your protection so just go ahead and get
boosted now's the time to do it as we're
getting into the holiday season you want
to be fully protected in the sense of
getting optimal i mean the vaccines
themselves clearly are still highly
effective but you want to make sure the
durability of that protection is longer
and that's the reason why you get
boosted because we know no vaccine lasts
forever so the the protection starts to
wane a bit and that's what the boost is
all about
protection starts to wane a bit
no vaccine lasts forever
um yeah it's been six months
six
this is like your your waiter at the
restaurant hands a bowl of spaghetti
with a giant turd in it and you complain
and he says well look no meal is perfect
six months
and his reasoning is oh it's not gonna
last forever
now they still won't come out and say
what has been clear from the beginning
but they still won't say it
because anthony fauci is allergic to the
truth
and also like we talked about at the
beginning this is all part of their
false reality so they they feel no
obligation to the truth whatsoever
they've completely severed themselves
from it
and they consider the truth itself to be
the enemy in fact
so that's why they've been lying the
whole time and they still will not come
out and say that listen this is endemic
it's going to be with us forever
you're always going to live in a world
with cover 19. you will never escape
that that's always going to be in the
world you'll you'll probably get it at
some point if you haven't already
most of you have probably already had it
even if you didn't know you did
and if you haven't had it yet you're
going to get it eventually every single
person on earth i think
we should just say this if it's if if
this has not been made clear to you yet
no matter who you are listening right
now
you you will at some point get covered
19.
you'll you will get it
just like at some point you you're gonna
get the flu you're probably not gonna
live your whole life and never get the
flu
um
it's endemic and that's what it means
when a virus respiratory virus is
endemic
but they still won't say that they'll
never say it
ten years from now they'll still be
doing segments like that
on cnn and he still won't say oh listen
this is just this is the way it is now
and uh you know they could say just like
the flu you know if there's there's a
different flu shot every year if you
want to be protected you got to get the
flu shot or or don't get it it's up to
you
they could say that with the covet
vaccine
you know
there's there was always new mutations
and everything it's endemic so you know
you're probably gonna have to get it
once a year or even more often if you
want
but they uh they they can't say that
because the other thing is if they say
that
kind of ironically it it you know it
makes people less afraid
in the long term it makes you less
afraid
to be told that well this is going to be
here forever then it just it becomes
part of your reality and you start to
get used to it i mean if they had said
that a year ago
if they had been honest a year ago
and said this is endemic we're always
going to have it with us get used to it
then by now i think a a large number of
people large majority people would be
kind of used to it
and then you start thinking about
masking and you would say well i mean
either i'm going to wear the mask
forever or i'm gonna stop wearing it now
because it doesn't make any sense either
you know i i can i can dispense with
this fantasy
that i'm gonna wear the mask for a short
period of time or a certain you know a
certain temporary period of time and
then stop wearing it
covet is here forever i can i can wear
the mask forever in response to that or
i can live my life
and they could have given people a
chance a year ago a year and a half ago
to make that to think of it in those
terms come to terms with it and make
their decisions
and if they had then there are a lot of
people right now who are not living
normal human lives who might be
but they don't want that they don't want
you living a normal human life they want
you in the mask they want you afraid
forever
and uh part of making that that again is
the irony of it part of making you
afraid of covid is to convince you
that soon it will go away
if you if you understand that it's here
forever you will actually be less afraid
of
it right um next what else we got quick
okay an update on this i mentioned st
louis university um
slu
you know i'm supposed to speak there on
december 1st that's next not this coming
wednesday but next wednesday
and um there's a petition that started
some of the leftist groups on campus and
i think this began with the
slu [ __ ]
that's what they call themselves that's
not my term for them they call
themselves the [ __ ] and so the [ __ ]
and some other people on slu they
started a petition to keep me off of
campus
and last i checked in fact i have it
right here
they got 1500
1574 signatures on the campus to keep me
off campus
on the basis that um i am dangerous and
that uh
you know i have a lot of
quote extremely controversial and
harmful opinions
like feminism is the worst thing ever
happened to human society and um
you know they say i'm very disrespectful
to my opponents i have called my
opponents stupid and morally deranged
and you know in response to that they
have come up with this stupid and
morally deranged petition as if to prove
my point for me and i appreciate that
so they got 1500
signatures
the keep matt walsh off of st louis
university campus
in response to that i started the keep
matt walsh on st louis university campus
and our petition at this point has um
we're at up to 18 000 signatures on that
and i'm not promoting it anymore i mean
i promoted it once
you know on on twitter i sent it out
there
and we doubled their signatures in 30
minutes and now we're at 18 000 they're
still stuck if so you know i think that
people have spoken this is democracy in
action
does that mean the university will
respect the will of the people
uh i don't know
or will they engage in an insurrection
by usurping the will of the people and
keeping me off of campus i'm not sure
about that i will tell you that uh the
administrators on slu were still working
through this you know they're
they're pulling all manner of dirty
tricks right now um trying to get the
event shut down or trying to convince me
to shut it down
um
so we're
fighting this behind the scenes as well
but one thing they're doing and this is
this is something that a lot of liberal
campuses have have cued on to is that
well just keep keep putting in all these
safe quote unquote safety measures
because of covid keep putting them in
place until you convince the speaker to
pull out because they don't want to be
they don't want to take part in the
whole charade anymore and so that's what
the administrators are doing right now
they let the
last i heard on friday they contacted
the conservative group college
republicans who were bringing me on
campus
and um they had a whole bevy of new
safety precautions they wanted to put in
place
and uh interestingly enough
shockingly
there have been other events on campus
in the last year where these safety
precautions have not been put in place
but they won't but for me they want them
so we're still working through that and
um but i'll tell you one thing as far as
i'm concerned no matter what
i am going to be on st louis university
campus next wednesday no matter what
one way or another i will be there
um
all right let's move now to the comment
section
[Music]
i got to keep learning this lesson with
me i am a i am a s
stubborn incorrigible
and the more you tell me that you don't
want me to do something and the more you
try to prevent me from doing it the more
i want to do it okay it is
it and a lot of that i would like to
pretend that this is all you know just
principle and virtue on my part
it's not a lot of it is just that i am a
childish sob
and when you tell me not to do something
i want to do it but but that's that's
how i am
so you're not going to keep me off i
will be there once again okay
this is uh from daniel says i love
matt's move with the whole slu scenario
it allows the sane normally ignored
majority to have its voice every other
conservative speaker
should take note thanks daniel the rose
says parents don't understand how
teaching works
quoting something we read on friday
yes this absolutely explains why
homeschoolers routinely outperform
institutionally educated children
yeah that's um that's one of the dirty
little secrets about homeschooling is
that academically
homeschoolers
often vastly outperform public schoolers
and that's that's true i think among
when it comes to socialization too
because that's another concern you
always hear about public school
homeschool kids is that they're not
properly socialized and they won't
develop the right social skills
well that's a harder thing to measure
than academic performance
but i think the proof is in the pudding
here and we can look at
public school kids
and the public school environment and
the culture in the public school system
and you can take a look at that and if
you've spent any time in it as i have i
spent 13 years in it from k through 12
when i went to public school
it's hard to argue that um
this is an environment that creates
socially well-adjusted mature people it
certainly doesn't
but academically yeah you're exactly
right and um
why is that i mean why
would homeschool kids
have an academic advantage over public
school kids one of the reasons
is that well for one thing in homeschool
most of the time you're not wasting time
on you know teaching kids critical race
theory and gender theory and
you know
and tolerance and all that kind of
diversity we're not wasting any time on
that we're getting right down to the
academics
but the other thing is that
one of the most important
resources
you can have as a teacher
is
a connection with and knowledge of your
students
because education is a personalized
thing
it's not something that you can
successfully do in a kind of conveyor
belt cookie cutter fashion
that's what they're trying to do in the
public school system they've been trying
to do it for decades it doesn't work
education is personalized
and as a parent
you know your kid better than anybody
else
you have a connection with your child
hopefully that their public school
teacher doesn't have and couldn't have
in fairness to the public school teacher
i mean they've got 30 kids in a room for
45 minutes at a time they can't develop
personal connection with uh
with all of those kids that you do to
have that as a parent and that means
that you understand what your kid needs
academically and how to reach them and
um you know how to keep them engaged
and that's a great that's a great
advantage that homeschool teachers have
um
se says
byu has similar problems where lgbtq and
like-minded groups are fighting for more
representation
but the lifestyle is not in line with
lds teachings these religious private
institutions are meant to promote higher
learning and be separate from the
world's views
they focus not only on logic but on
moral truth
uh the hope is that you graduate with
more knowledge of the world and come out
a more spiritually enlightened person
uh they'd be crazy not to let you speak
by the way i'd argue that first wave
feminist ideas voting rights education
the ability to choose a specific job or
career is fine
it's what came after that poisoned
everything and turned feminism into a
bad word
well i agree with the first part of what
you said not the second part
um
as i as i've been explaining you know
feminism
you could go go back to the founders of
feminism
and read what they had to say about
religion christianity the bible the
family marriage men
feminism from the very beginning has
been an anti-family anti-male
anti-religious phenomenon
there have been exceptions from the
beginning but those exceptions have
always been exceptions
and that shouldn't really surprise us
because
when
this idea that like first wave feminism
in the early 20th century it was pure
and right and good
and then within a few decades it's
it's arguing for the mass slaughter of
babies
i mean if your movement goes from one
thing to within a few years arguing from
mass slaughter babies
that's a pretty good indication that
something was wrong from the beginning i
mean there is something foundationally
wrong with with your movement
now we know the the saying about about
all movements is that uh eventually they
become you know a business and a racket
and and and maybe that's true
but if the business of your movement
again with only within only a few years
or decades
is to kill babies then that tells you
that there's something wrong at its root
i mean feminism is sick at its root
it may have had a few goals early on
that were
commendable
um
but that doesn't change the fact that
it's poisoned at its roots and now a
word from one of my favorite sponsors
american financing if it feels like
everything costs more these days
including the cost to borrow money well
uh that's because it is everything is
more expensive uh well at least for some
things like credit cards and personal
loans but mortgages still have
incredibly low rates which means you
should really be looking at your home
loan and all of your debt for that
matter and figuring out ways to save
money because you got money you know if
we all do with all the bills we pay
every month just money leaking out of
your accounts
you can put a pin in some of that now uh
and uh that's what you need american
financing for this is a family-owned
lender that's known for saving people up
to a thousand dollars a month from lower
interest rates to more competitive terms
or even the ability to access cash they
can do all of that and much more and you
don't have to reset your loan to get
these kinds of savings you can choose
any term 10 years and over because you
shouldn't pay interest for five for
years that you don't need so to
pre-qualify for free call
1-866-569-4711 that's 866
4711 or visit americanfinancing.net
you know if you've been worrying about
what you're going to get your loved ones
this christmas then i have excellent
news for you the daily wire merch store
is here and ready to be explored yes you
heard that right daily wire merch is
finally here people ask me actually do
ask me this a lot like why don't we have
merchandise well we finally do and we
have it just in time for the holidays so
um i know for me all that's my whole
family all they're getting is daily wire
merchandise especially because it's free
for me so i'm not going to spend a dime
and i'm going to give everybody my own
merchandise and that's the kind of gift
quality that they expect for me head to
dailywire.com
shop to check out the collection of
let's go brandon tailgate gear our
poster collection of the founding
fathers drinking leftist tears and so so
much more anyone can shop at the daily
wire store but only daily wire members
will get special discounts up to 20 off
members also receive access to shop
exclusive merch like the daily wire
leftist tears tumbler which holds more
leftist tears than the average man knows
what to do with and of course i have my
section on the shop as well and if
you're wondering can you get the sweet
baby gang shirts there you absolutely
can so head to the dailywire.com
shop to get a little something for
everyone on your list who loves brandon
or is a member of the sweet baby gang
even if they're not a member of the
sweet baby gang still get them sweet
baby gang shirt that's their gift for
christmas you're inducting them into the
gang and they will love it trust me and
if you sign up right now become a member
at dailywire.com subscribe you can get
35 off your membership and use if you
want to do that use code dw35
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we cancel the fight for 15
movement though this may be redundant
because it has mostly canceled itself
for several years
we were told that 15 an hour is the be
all and end all if only every worker in
america could be paid at least 15 an
hour then there would be no more poverty
no more hunger no more climate change
i'm not totally sure about that last one
i meant that last one as kind of a joke
but i'm sure if i googled it i would
discover that at least one member of the
squad has made an argument at some point
that a minimum wage of less than 15 an
hour causes climate change i'm just
assuming that someone has said that
or maybe not merely less than 15 because
after years of clamoring for 15 fighting
for 15 over the last year we've seen
many headlines like this in teen vogue
15
minimum wage isn't enough for workers to
afford rent in any u.s state
and this and yahoo 15 an hour isn't
enough u.s workers need a living wage
fight for 15 never mind that's not
enough
this is of course the unbroken pattern
with all progressive causes set a goal
make it the ultimate objective the final
summit to be climbed
and then as soon as you get there to
your destination promptly declare that
it's paltry and insignificant and we
must set course for some farther
destination anybody who thinks that you
should be satisfied with where you
currently are is a monster a bigot a
racist a nazi and worst of all somehow
also probably a transphobe this is the
flight path for all forms of leftist
activism
and now we know the next stop it will
only be a a brief layover we can be sure
but a viral post on twitter has been
making the rounds posted originally by a
self-described trans-indigenous
journalist with they them pronouns it
proclaims that the new slogan is this
25 or walk
potential job applicants are called to
engage in a mcdonald's employment
boycott
what this means is that they must refuse
to work at mcdonald's they must work
anywhere but mcdonald's
until the fast food chain will pay a
thriving wage of 25 an hour
i mean who needs a living wage anymore
let's go for a thriving wage
it also calls for a disruption of
mcdonald's hiring resources
you're encouraged to apply for a job
schedule the interview
and then either either never show for
the interview or accept the job but
don't show up to work the idea is to
focus the energy on one company bully
them into raising their wage to 25 an
hour
and then wait for the other dominoes to
fall
there are some problems with this idea
and they're mostly the same problems
with the fight for 15 movement
um and you know when it comes and then
it'll be the same problems when it
becomes the fight for 35 movement and
the fight for 55 and the flight fight
for 600 an hour
these same problems will still persist
so let's go through a few of them very
quickly
and this is far from an exhaustive list
but here goes first you're not going to
bully mcdonald's into paying you 25 an
hour
you will however bully them into
replacing you with automated touch
screens as they've already begun doing
in locations all over all over the world
now i am personally not a fan of this
trend i would prefer to see actual human
beings working these jobs
i also don't like having to touch the
same screen that 500 greasy fingered
people before me touched
and the catch-22 as always is that none
of the human workers in the building
have the skill or knowledge required to
fix the automated systems when they
malfunction
humans are replaced by technology that
they don't know how to operate or fix
we're literally two steps away from
terminator at this point all that to say
i take no satisfaction in seeing
positions eliminated as robots are
substituted for human workers but this
is what is happening and will continue
to happen
and the more you fight to make
low-skilled jobs as expensive as
possible for employers the more you
guarantee that those jobs won't exist in
the future
second
i really hate the snobby elitist
attitude that many people have towards
blue collar jobs
you know a lot of kids pick this pick
this up back in grade school when
they're told by their teachers and
guidance counselors that if they don't
go to college and get the kind of job
that requires a college degree
they're going to be miserable failures
in life
if they take this propaganda at face
value and they go to college even if
they graduate and end up unemployed and
living at their parents house still they
feel entitled to turn their noses up at
people who work for a living and
oftentimes make a lot more money than
they do which isn't hard if they're
unemployed
there are many and i mean hundreds and
hundreds of jobs so-called blue-collar
jobs that don't require college
education and yet and yet do require
specialized skill and you can make a
very respectable living in them while
also providing necessary goods and
services to the public mechanics
plumbers electricians just a few
examples
these are jobs where you should be able
to and certainly can earn both a living
wage and a thriving wage
not because the government mandates it
but because you earn it
but
running a cash register at a fast food
chain is not one of those kinds of jobs
entry level fast fast-food jobs are very
very low-skilled
being a mechanic is not low-skilled
running a cash register at a fast food
joint is
it's so low-skilled that a 12-year-old
could do it if not for child labor laws
there's a reason the positions can so
easily be replaced by touch screens i
mean you're doing a job that the
customer can do themselves
this this weekend we needed a new water
heater at our house and some some guys
came this weekend to uh to install it i
can't do that myself
i needed someone with their skills to do
it i can however punch my own order into
the screen at mcdonald's i can even bag
my own food if we want to do it buffet
style
it's a job that requires no specialized
skill of any kind
all workers in all fields at all jobs
are technically replaceable one of the
reasons as i always say that you should
find meaning in your family more than
you do at work
but the difference is that an entry
level fast food worker is very very
easily replaced
because literally almost anybody on
earth can do that job
now i don't say this as an insult to
people who work those jobs i worked in
them too when i was a teenager
that's because those kinds of jobs along
with the minimum wage itself are made
for teenagers they're not intended to be
a career
you're not supposed to be trying to live
off them 25 an hour
that's what mechanics and technicians
and athletic trainers and sheet metal
workers make
those are jobs again that require
training and skill they couldn't just
pull anybody off the street give them a
name tag and a 30 minute orientation
expect them to do it
but that is the case with entry level
fast food and i keep stressing entry
level because there are jobs in the food
industry which do require a great amount
of skill and do pay a living wage or
even a thriving wage and should
salting the fries or punching an order
into the cash register aren't among
those jobs
which is why you shouldn't try to make
yourself comfortable or satisfied with
those jobs
and that brings us to the third point
the focus on minimum wage is is
depressing
it's a kind of despair
let's make sure people can live on the
minimum
why the minimum i mean what sort of
mantra is that what sort of mission is
that
it's the mission of people who want us
all to be fed and satiated but not
fulfilled
despite what the twitter post said they
don't want us to thrive
there's a reason they want us all living
in pods and eating bugs
if the goal is to thrive and that should
indeed be the goal
then pressing buttons and wearing a
visor and a name tag ought to be treated
as a very temporary stepping stone not a
career option not a lifestyle choice
i mean even if we could flip a magic
switch and ensure that you can live off
of even financially thrive off of
entry-level fast food jobs you still
wouldn't really be thriving because
you'd still be doing a mostly mindless
job that requires no skill
it's a job that you can't really put any
of yourself into
you're still a very replaceable cog in a
dehumanizing machine
nobody should be satisfied with that
so let's stop worrying about the minimum
and worry about moving past that
which again anyone can do that's the
good news if you're if you're stuck at a
minimum wage job at a fast food place
and you want to move up to the next uh
the next step
and move beyond that all you got to do
tuck your shirt in
show up to work on time
be reliable
be at least moderately cheerful with the
customers that's the hardest part of the
job believe me i know
do that for six months and you're
already going to get a promotion
because the bar is so low
and that should be the goal
not the minimum wage
which is why today
the minimum the entire minimum wage in
fact i think is cancelled and we'll
leave it there for today thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
dailywire2021
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire
on today's episode the written house
verdict sparks both protests and support
concerns grow over the safety of a
chinese tennis star and thanksgiving
costs climb
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire